[Musique]
avec voilà une phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse internationale et la destruction
hier par l'armée russe on a parlé à
l'instant avec damien coq et d'un
complexe militaire à l'ouest de
l'ukraine bombardement qui a fait au
moins 35 morts et plus de 130 blessés la
russie bombarde provoque le temps gazeta
wyborcza précise que ces bombardements
se sont produits à une vingtaine de
kilomètres seulement de la pologne le
quotidien polonais évoquent un signal
envoyé par moscou à l'alliance qui
utilisent depuis des années ces
installations militaires comme centre
d'entraînement des forces du craignait
mais aussi comme centre de transit pour
des livraisons d'armes de financial
times par le lui on le voit d'un
avertissement d'un message sévère lancé
par la divers poutine alliance militaire
dirigée par les états unis le quotidien
britannique cite entre autres l'analyse
de l'expert polonais daniel chez ligue
au ski qui perçoit ces bombardements
comme un doigt d'honneur je le cite
adressé par moscou à washington pressée
de réagir avec fermeté j'espère que
l'administration maiden comprendra enfin
le message et dire désormais ce qu'elle
fera plutôt que ce qu'elle ne fera pas
entendez une intervention militaire
directe cette frustration est d'ailleurs
partagée par le wall street journal qui
estime que poutine exploite les lignes
rouges établi par bayonne contre une
intervention américaine et que le
président russe profite pleinement de la
volonté de son homologue américain
d'éviter à tout prix une escalade ce
scénario d'ailleurs d'une possible
escalade inquiète le frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung pour le quotidien
allemand l'attak d'hyères n'est pas une
surprise et les alliés doivent prendre
garde à contenir ce conflit et ne pas
l'aggraver quel commentaire en russie un
des avis immédiat gazeta justifie ces
bombardements par le fait que l'otan
serait en train de préparer l'ukraine à
une contre offensive je cite plus
globalement le quotidien russe accuse le
camp occidental de chercher à isoler la
russie sur la scène internationale une
campagne baptisée comme celle rachat en
référence au phénomène de cancelles
culture dans les pays anglo saxons à
laquelle le kremlin réplique notamment
par la voix de son
des finances ici elle a une en disant
vouloir renforcer sa coopération
économique avec la chine d'après le new
york times qui cite des responsables
américains moscou a est également
demandé à pékin une assistance militaire
demande dont le porte-parole de
l'ambassade chinoise à washington
déclare n'avoir jamais entendu parler la
chine cherche avant tout selon lui un
règlement pacifique
est ce qu ont fui la guerre en ukraine
qui a aussi des conséquences
religieusement parlais tout à l'heure
avec jonathan walsh depuis kiev l'église
orthodoxe qui dépend du patriarcat de
moscou prend de plus en plus ses
distances avec vladimir poutine lacroix
fait état de déchirements au sein de
l'orthodoxie et de l'appel du
métropolite de lviv en faveur d'une
église orthodoxe indépendante de moscou
la russie est l'agresseur elle attaque
l'ukraine et le patriarche kirill ne
reconnaît pas cette réalité justifie
l'arrêt une position partagée notamment
par une paroisse orthodoxe d'amsterdam
selon le guardian qui rappelle que le
patriarche kirill qui est un allié de
confiance du président russe vladimir
poutine a qualifié les opposants de la
russie en ukraine de forces du mal et
également déclaré la semaine dernière
que les défilé de la fierté homosexuelle
dans les pays de l'ouest faisait partie
des raisons de cette guerre en ukraine
la guerre nuque reine hélène sur
laquelle on va revenir juste après votre
revue de presse et sur laquelle vont
s'exprimer ce soir lors d'une émission
télé les huit principaux candidats à la
présidentielle française dont emmanuel
macron leur faut le président et ses
adversaires vous expliquer leur position
mais sans échanger sans se confronter ni
même se croiser autrement dit sans
débattre une formule inédite à la
demande expresse des manuels macron
selon l'opinion ou le dessin de cas
qu'on le voit montre les sept
adversaires du président tester face à
lui tout au bout de cette table
poutinienne une configuration critiqué
par les candidats qu'ils jugent
machiavélique la proposition de l'elysée
c'était à prendre ou à laisser je cite
macron veut donner l'impression qu'il
fait un débat sans faire de débat ap par
son agenda international ultra favori le
chef de l'état fait campagne par
intermittence et ne se risque guère au
débat avec ses adversaires libération
regrette que cette actu ite ukrainienne
agissent comme un nez tout foire sur la
course à l'elysée lacroix enfin relais
les critiques sur la gestion solitaire
du président de la crise à l'ukraine à
ces initiatives diplomatiques pour
l'ukraine en passant par sa déclaration
de candidature à la toute dernière
minute rien de tout cela n'a permis à
emmanuel macron de se défaire vraiment
de l'image d'arrogance voire de mépris
qui lui colle à la peau depuis ses
années au ministère de l'économie et
puis le retour du sourire ou de la
mousse et selon hélène une bonne
nouvelle enfin on l'espère dans ce
contexte difficile la fin du masque et
du pass vaccinale en france après deux
années de restrictions mais les français
peuvent enfin respirer
en dépit du léger regain des
contaminations le figaro se réjouit de
pouvoir enfin enlever ce masque estime
qu'il est temps désormais pauline de
passer à autre chose au lieu de
surveiller comme le lait sur le feu les
courbes de contamination on ferait mieux
de s'interroger sur l'avenir de notre
abyssal dette publique c'est plus
réjouissant en effet la reprise
épidémique constaté ces derniers jours
n'a pas incité le gouvernement en pleine
campagne présidentielle
à revoir sa décision de lever les
restrictions sanitaires quitte à
aggraver la situation prévient pour sa
part l'humanité
bye bye les masques pour aujourd'hui en
tout cas et seulement pour aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être une bonne nouvelle et la
dépêche du midi ne boude pas son plaisir
et ma foi nous non plus et donc merci
beaucoup et l'aisne